[MUSIC]
T-Square is the learning management
system that we use at Georgia Tech,
not just in the OMSCS program,
but on campus as well.
You'll access T-Square at
t-square.gatech.edu or
you can always get to
it through BuzzPort.
Now, different classes use T-Square
differently, but generally speaking,
T-Square is the hub of the course.
It's where you'll access syllabi,
assignments,
assignment submission, grades,
Piazza, Udacity and more.
Now some classes might put some of
these materials on to other sites, but
generally you'll get to
it through T-Square.
So we're going to talk about
how to access T-Square and
some of the tools you'll use through
T-Square in many of your courses.